BEEN TOLD FROM RECENT DAYS.
>> Sean: JOHN SOLOMON, JOINING
US NOW WITH REACTION, OUR TOP
STORY.
THAT STORY,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM.
N CATHOLIC, BRUCE OHR, THE FIRST
FISA WARRANT WAS EVER SIGNED,
SAYING THAT STEELE HATES
TRUMP, AND IT IS UNVERIFIED.
THEN HE HEARD WHAT
ROD ROSENSTEIN SAID.
AND YOU HEARD JOHN SOLOMON, HELP
ME OUT, SENATOR.
IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE THEY
PREMEDITATED CONSPIRACY TO
COMMIT FRAUD OF THE COURT TO
UNDO A FIRST STOP AND THEN UNDO
A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, THAT'S
HOW I INTERPRET IT.
>> McCABE ALSO SAID WITHOUT
THE DOSSIER THERE WOULD HAVE
BEEN NO WAR ISSUED AGAINST
CARTER PAGE.
SO McCABE SAYS UNDER OATH AND
IT WAS OUT COME DETERMINE.
AND EVERYTHING YOU SAY ABOUT THE
GARBAGE OF THE DOSSIER IS TRUE,
BUT THIS IS WHEN WE HAD
MR. HORWITZ LOOKING INTO THIS.
AND I CANNOT WAIT UNTIL HE TELLS
US WHAT HE FOUND.
>> Sean: WHERE DO YOU GO WITH
THIS?
YOU ARE THE ONE GUY THAT CAN
BRING THEM ALL IN.
AND I REALLY DO HOPE, SENATOR,
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT DID THIS
WERE ALSO INVOLVED IN RIGGING
THE INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY.
THE EVIDENCE IS PRETTY
OVERWHELMING THAT SHE VIOLATED
THE ESPIONAGE ACT AND THEN
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE.
FROM MY LITTLE TV STUDIO, THE
LITTLE THAT I KNOW ABOUT THESE
THINGS.
>> I DON'T WANT TO ASK COMEY,
WHAT DID YOU TELL THE PRESIDENT
IN JANUARY 2017?
HERE IS THE DOSSIER, I CAN'T
VERIFY IT, WHY DON'T YOU KNOW
ABOUT IT?
AND USE THE SAME DOCUMENT AND
TOLD THE COURT THAT IT WAS
RELIABLE ON FOUR DIFFERENT
OCCASIONS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHEN McCABE
REAFFIRMED AGAIN THAT WITHOUT
THE DOSSIER THAT THERE WILL BE
NO WARRANT?
I WANT TO FIND OUT THAT DID
PAPADOPOULOS TELL THEM UPFRONT
THAT I WAS WORKING WITH THE
RUSSIANS THAT WOULD BE A CRIME
AND I WOULD NEVER DO THAT.
I WANT TO KNOW A BUNCH OF THING
THINGS.
>> Sean: I WANT TO KNOW A LOT.
HE WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF ALL
OF THAT.
I WILL ASK YOU THIS QUESTION.
WE HAVE NEW LEADERSHIP.
THE 2020 DEMOCRATIC HOPEFULS ALL
SEEM TO BE REACTING TO AND
ADOPTING THE POLICIES OF THE
SQUAD, I GUESS THEY ARE CALLED
NOW, AND I THINK I LOOK AT THE
NEW GREEN DEAL, AND I LOOK AT
EVERY DEMOCRAT SAYING YES,
EVERYTHING IS FREE.
NO OIL, NO GAS, NO PLANES OR
COWS, AND I SAID THAT IS THE END
OF THE UNITED STATES AS WE KNOW
IT IF THAT IS EVER IMPLEMENTED.
>> THE POLICY CHOICES WOULD
DEVASTATE FREE ENTERPRISE AND
MAKE US WEAK.
IT WOULD BE THE END OF THIS
WORLD AS WE KNOW IT.
IT WOULD BE DEVASTATING TO THE
AMERICAN WAY OF LIFE, OUR
PROSPERITY.
COMPARE THAT TO WHAT TRUMP IS
DOING.
NAME ONE PERSON IN MY LIFETIME
THAT HAS BEEN A BETTER FRIEND TO
ISRAEL AND HAS A STRENGTH OF THE
ECONOMY IN DECADES, AND THE
MILITARY ON PAR WITH WHAT
RONALD REAGAN DID.
ANTIFOREIGN POLICY THAT MAKES
SENSE.
I THINK COMPARE AND CONTRAST
CAMPAIGN IS GOING TO LEAD TO A
VERY BIG TRUMP VICTORY.
>> Sean: OKAY, SO IN THE TIME
THAT DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN
ELECTED UNTIL NOW, DO YOU THINK
THAT HE HAS LOST ANY, OR SOME OF
THE SUPPORTERS?
THEY SEEM PRETTY PASSIONATE IN
NORTH CAROLINA, AND DO YOU THINK
MAYBE THE BEST EMPLOYMENT
SITUATION SINCE 1969 AND BELOW
UNEMPLOYMENT FOR ALL OF THESE
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUPS, AND SOME
THAT VOTE DEMOCRATIC, DO YOU
THINK HE HAS A SHOT AT THOSE
VOTERS NOW?
>> I THINK THAT HE HAS UNITED
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC -- --
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
EVERYBODY BELIEVES THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS DOING A GREAT
JOB WITH A FEW OUTLIERS.
IF YOU BELIEVE IN CUTTING TAXES
AS A CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN THE
GUM HE DID IT.
IF YOU BELIEVE AS A CONSERVATIVE
JUDGE, NOBODY HAS DONE BETTER.
FROM A REPUBLICAN POINT OF VIEW,
YOU DON'T HAVE A LOT TO COMPLAIN
ABOUT.
COMPARE THAT TO OUR FRIENDS ON
THE OTHER SIDE WHO ARE CRACKING
UP.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, SENATOR,
TELL US HOW YOU REALLY FEEL.